platz weil dann vielleicht sogar
ausrichtung zukünftiger willkommen zu
einem neuen die leute ich war ja das
wochenende über einen charakter bis
montag jetzt ging für deutschlands
größter auch wieder zurück in einem
neuen video verfolgung ich weiß bei
riesiger zusammen video aufgenommen und
habe dem video karriere video auf
youtube in deutschland vom vater
natürlich wer daneben
ich habe eigentlich schon ziemlich
heikle thema welches dann noch ein video
youtube für die anderen arbeitet sich
ein viertel reduziert und immer ehrlich
darüber zu reden oder auch händels heute
bietet aber meine top 3 auch stellen
also die meiner meinung nach reichen
über deutschland
in diesem video seht ihr wie viel die 15
erfolgreichsten youtuber deutschlands
für ihre views bekommen haben nicht mit
eingerechnet ist natürlich die kohle
durch werbung merchandise und
öffentliche auftritte die frage ob
youtube erklärung alles andere sind
nicht miteingerechnet
das ist so und so viele mittel ist sehr
ungenau ist meine erfahrung und alle
aller dinge außenrum in dem monat immer
noch doppelt oder dreimal youtube
erreicht haben sein kann
juli in q1 10 4 millionen euro insgesamt
also mit einrechnung slams rausgenommen
nicht glauben wie die sich die
kommerzielle schiene serie spiel glaube
ich dass platz 14 für juli angesagt zu
niedrig ist also einfach mal davon aus
dass youtube vor steuern verdient haben
auch jeweils auch mal ausrechnen dass
prozent in deutschland vermögensklassen
die hälfte nummer reagiert vorteil
bringt ricoh auf jeden fall julian b 10
203 millionen euro weniger professionell
natürlich auch jemand seines hoch
positiven inhalten geeignet für
kooperationen mit unternehmen und der
dinge die kooperation
unternehmensvertreter theatralisch
irgendwann auch für suri und bären zu
niedrig und müsse deutlich weiter oben
sein und weil aber zwischendurch
natürlich nicht feststeht oben in der
liste der vermögendsten youtube ist
schlechtes werke die 137 9 millionen
euro wie in meinen augen auch ein
ähnlicher fall greift vielleicht war ich
drin der wichtigsten kann eben nicht
beurteilen ich viele
produktplatzierungen oder kooperativen
linie zwar jemand würde aber wir
vermuten dass da geht ihm sicher auch
vormachen und raucher über in houston
auch werke passiert also ich auch nach
elf ist
bis zum rechner muss aufhören wer wie
inside als 388 millionen euro
wie auch viel zu niedrige gemeinde
selbst dass er gerade an den plan hilft
haben noch ein paar plätze zu machen und
einfach mit übersicht zu kaufen die
ganze firma zu kaufen und dann in drei
jahren auch google und youtube eine
absicht werk noch ein bisschen bei
versprach zu können dementsprechend
bücher wie ihn zeit und der liste der
reichsten youtuber deutschland auf platz
neun vor ort die lobbys 1,52 millionen
euro loch ist auch selber palocci wer
bei proben für sich durch auch weil
aktiv vermarkten da einen sehr großen
teil einnimmt und deutlich über die
werbeeinnahmen ausgeht wesel die der
physiker auch über den crafter 164
millionen euro
contento 19 36 millionen euro im
zweifelsfall nicht deutlich geringer
ansetzen würde kleine video geht es nur
um ein haben sich interviews unter
extrem viele hughes gemacht noch mal
sagen dass 837.000 abonnenten und da
auch eine milliarde aufruf über eine
milliarde komplett gestört aber weiter
und wenn du im gaming content machten
sein gesicht nicht so oft weit denke ich
dass die vermarktungsmöglichkeiten nicht
so gut sind über analysiert über wirte
und händler deswegen deutlich weiter
hinten setzen auf jeden fall hinter den
loches dieser luca felix von der lage 20
5 millionen euro der fall wo ich sagen
würde dass die inflation gefährlich
gucken wie gemacht angeht hat ja auch
schon sein eigenes unternehmen in die
richtung gegründet ich merke man
normalerweise eher weniger auftauchen
was ziemlich krass was für eine kasse
darüber geht soeben in deutschland
unfassbar oder generiert dass die
einnahme von irgendwelchen youtuber
nicht dass ich je auf einem
youtube-video sein dass man darüber
nicht reden wird oder nicht reparieren
die kommentare reichen denkt ihr geld
ist ein thema über das man reden kann
darf auch direkt öffentlichen seine
violetten recht offen mit dem thema um
wenn irgendwo eine frage zu bekommen
jeglichen der regel auch mit antibiotika
als 2,8 millionen euro gebracht und
deutlich jetzt so wie ich würde ich
eigentlich auf platz 1 in deutschland
setzen oder apotheken ersten platz
vielleicht nicht gerade billig somit gab
es über dem nord vermarktung angeht
produkte auf dem roman geht was auch die
wehrmacht eigenen channel angehende zehn
minuten videos hat mitgemacht genau wie
der jaguar verfügt jahren haft dazu dass
man einfach extrem viel kohle verdient
mit den fingern würde glaube ich wird
auch im kommenden märz kanzlerin zu
graffiti die arbeiten derweil weiter
vielleicht sogar aus richtung zu gehen
oder sogar einige rechtliche reparierten
war nicht ganz so viele user heiratet
vermarktungstechnisch also alles andere
profis weise sofort an gibt sehr gut ich
würde der greenback platz zwei und drei
ist auch wieder relativ schwer zu
unterscheiden welche ziele jedenfalls
nicht zu sagen piep mit kommen auf jeden
fall in frage
die woche eventuell den vergangenen
schweren darüber ab stufe zu machen auf
platz drei also meine allgemeine
bewerten möchte wie viele nicht verdient
weil das interessiert muss man nicht
noch die user auch extrem attraktiv
macht die längerfristige kooperation mit
unternehmen lukrative wie viel verkaufte
gleich ein wörtchen und eben brecht
eigenen produkte auf dem markt kann
sogar für einen wie dusche auge lachte
wie deutlich mehr gewicht kann am ende
der ganze
mit diesem video heute ein kleineres
bringen die meisten hören die region
erfahren idee bekannte persönlichkeit
weiter video und hier passend zum thema
leute die nachfolge von buffett geht vom
pro klick werde ich selbstverständlich
einmal kohle auch bewiesen werden könnte
gerne mal reinschauen